Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have reached a lot of milestones lately.
For instance, we now have over one million
views on the channel. In the next few days
we're also hoping to hit ten thousand subscribers.
To put it in perspective, in 2015 August 20th,
we have had a 250 subscriber special episode
where my mind was pretty much blown. That
was only about 9 months ago. Whoa.
For the record, here is an image that supposedly
contains ten thousand people. Just imagine
that they all have doctoral hats and you immediately
have a mental image of ten thousand of our
Fellow Scholars. It's insanity.
And I must say that I am completely blown
away by your loyal support. Thanks so much
for everyone for the many kind messages, comments
and e-mails, of which I'll read quite a few
in a second. It just boggles the mind to see
that so many people are interested in learning
more about awesome new research inventions,
and I hope that it is as addictive to you
as it was for me when I first got to see some
of these results.
A huge thank you also to our generous supporters
on Patreon, I find it really amazing that
we have quite a few Fellow Scholars out there
who love the series so much that they are
willing to financially help our cause. Just
think about it. Especially given that fact
that it's not easy to make ends meet these
days, I know this all too well being a full
time researcher, doing Two Minute Papers and
having a baby is extremely taxing, but I love
it. I really do. And I know there are people
who have it way worse, and here we have these
Fellow Scholars who believe in this cause
and are willing to help out. Thanks so much
for each one of you, I am honored to have
loyal supporters like you.
We are more than halfway there towards our
first milestone on Patreon, which means that
our hardware and software costs can be completely
covered with your help. As you know, we have
really cool perks for our Patrons. One of
these perks is that, for instance, our Professors
can decide the order of the next episodes,
and I was really surprised to see that this
episode won by a record number of points.
Looks like you Fellow Scholars are really
yearning for some story time, so let's bring
it on!
The focus of Two Minute Papers has always
been what a work is about and why it is important.
It has always been more about intuition than
specific details. That is the most important
reason why Two Minute Papers exists. But this
sounds a bit cryptic, so let me explain myself.
Most materials on any scientific topic on
YouTube are about details. When this big deep
learning rage started, and it was quite fresh,
I wanted to find out what deep learning was.
I haven't found a single video that was not
at least 30-90 minutes long, and all of them
talked about partial derivatives and the chain
rule, but never explained what we're exactly
doing and why we are doing it. It took me
four days to get a good grasp, a good high-level
intuition of what is going on.
I would have loved to have a resource that
explains this four days worth of research
work in just two minutes in a way that anyone
can understand. Anyone. I haven't found anything,
and this was just one example of many. Gandhi
said "Be the change that you wish to see in
the world", and this is how Two Minute Papers
was born. It has never been about the details, it has always been about intuition